сподіваюся савченко не допускають особливо
російських медики його українців не
допускає дунаєм лікорис України в
тисячу ростові-на-дону вал та й кликала
вид цей савченко до сильного 30 і
за словами та адвоката в українській
льотчиці determine про ван відкидні ми
особисто та обстеженню ще правильно вийти
сухого та ваня україна офіційно
загорнула сяду не матчами з проходимо на
про ось цю надію савченко німецьких
лікарів про нові руку не вдалося ipad
працювати до українки нової та я не про
дня проводи на
і виходьте стіл і таки самого фіза
розумієте на синематики колорит руди по
яким насичувати може ніби прямо
на правді я ставлюся монетам про в'язницю
я сьогодні мотому до зустрічі їх тарифів та
це куди спрямовані та побачите
федерального канцлера та копита її були
першими до вітрило
причому вона порадує не український посол
розкрито кого за травневий ульот за
позицію сюди мінських догляд за словом та
дипломатів провину за пробуксовувати не
мирного процесу перикла дають на україну
оберлін занатта дружно ставиться до
Москви вам за знімає чини з
співпереживати in that is no 1 руку париж
і міністр за кордон aspro поза машиною за
іклів у бути дві сторони наріжте
задуму тисяча годині тут немає їх
рук і ніг і дрифтів вони мінська наплутала
них щури
ми можемо ніби йому про тисячу берлін за
тато діставайте до Москви
Але поки німецької депутати так і
заповнюючі негайно не загриз росії
і знайдено зроби криму вони дивом
мирного процесу вони рахунки справи
савченко берлін то в ряд фарин роблять
багатий у умань бурштиновому плані на всіх
ременях ціна тиру чеки та повалятися
публічно їх ви і жартую fat and see ну я
виходжу стіл що справа савченко
адже граючи роль у всіх переговорах
карла gheorghe в лиман так разу значився
позиції не меч чина змінився і
прослуховування санкції проти Росії
нової ти малюк зрештою куди мінську і роки
будуть повністю ви каноне